all right guys bang-bang I've got Josh
here with me thanks so much for jumping
on doing this yeah absolutely excited it
sure let's let's start right off with a
bang
you had a wedding in Ireland and you had
a damn falcon fly the Rings to the I
guess altar what were you thinking you
know and if I'm gonna drag people all
the way to Ireland for a wedding I want
to make sure that it's something pretty
unforgettable and I'm a huge nerd and
while my wife is very classy very very
formal very fancy I wanted something
that was a bit more Lord of the Rings so
we got a herring a special type of hawk
so basically deliver the Rings straight
down the aisles to me at the altar and
I'd attach them for the wings and the
Falcons had to fly away in the middle of
the ceremony but I managed to hold on to
him and then he went up and perched on
the top of the castle to watch the rest
of the show and so this is a place that
they trained the Falcons to do this
right yeah so the the castle actually
has an on site like falconry
establishment which this seems right out
of a storybook but with like a weird
capitalist twist yeah I love that and
then what was the the reason for going
to Ireland just that that's specific
place or any other meaning behind it
my wife's Irish and we really wanted to
like honour her family I'm half English
so I've got a bunch of family over there
and we wanted someplace where there was
no curfew we actually ended up dancing
till about 4:30 in the morning and
didn't go to bed till sunrise but here
in Northern California they shut you
down at 10 p.m. because everyone in wine
country is a little bit too cautious
yeah that makes sense
so let's move from Falcons to Twitter
while you were having a pretty a pretty
incredible wedding you've also been a
I'll say staunch critic of Twitter and
and my take on your criticisms is less
like hey Twitter sucks and more just
like there's a lot of missed
opportunities and kind of what could
have been let's walk through some of
them
starting with just the lack of the
ability to clean the feed and how it
leads to kind of a worse experience
maybe explain that so the problem with
Twitter is even with its new algorithmic
you sort of get stingy once you feel
like your feet is full start to miss
people that you really care about the
people that you really love and you want
to see all of their tweets if you start
to miss those you become a lot more
cautious about adding new people and the
problem is that Twitter has never given
you an easy way to figure out who you
shouldn't follow I think they're a
little bit scared about offending
someone nobody wants to be on the
unfollow list right but still they need
some way of saying hey you've never
replied liked retweeted this person you
clearly don't care about them but we
keep showing you them and they're in
your feed but do you just want to get
rid of them entirely and if it did this
across the board our feeds would get
denser they'd be higher quality and
people would be more generous with their
follows and new people joining these
networks would have a chance because
right now the only people who really
have more than a million followers or so
are either real celebrities or people
who are on super early that first wave
of journalists and that makes it really
tough for the next generation of news
breakers of influencers of people who
have something to say to breakthrough
yeah and do you think that this is
something where Twitter could like
improve the algorithm and actually solve
it for us or is this something where
they've got to give the tools to the
user and then allow the user to actually
solve the problem for themselves I think
the problem is there are a lot of
lurkers on Twitter people who don't
necessarily want to hit that like or
that reply button they don't want to
jump into the conversation and be part
of the arena but they want to consume
and Twitter isn't really understanding
what is what they can't tell which tweet
on the screen you're looking at or what
what other signals to use if you're not
giving those explicit signals and so it
can only do so much with its algorithm
and it surely is doing a better job than
when it was an unranked feed and just
totally chronological but you know
you're seeing networks like Instagram
starting to show you the people you
interact with least so that you could
unfollow them and I think that that's a
lot better
wave than just leaving this entirely up
to people because if you've ever tried
to clean up your Twitter followers and
look through the people you're following
and look through you know each person oh
is this person interesting are the last
five tweets they sent actually relevant
to me it takes forever I get a few an
hour to get through a half dozen people
yeah one of the things that's really
interesting
- is how this parlays into the user
metrics I know you've written a couple
of times about how Twitter's
incentivized to basically keep as many
people on the platform as possible and
so that one is you want as many
connections as possible you want as much
content but also things around free
speech and all of that maybe kind of
explain the connection between the
inability or making it difficult for
people to clean the feed and how that
can drive user metrics I think that
Twitter has been in this very precarious
position for years now where its growth
rate is only just good enough to keep
people from saying oh this is this
company's in trouble you know it's not
shrinking but it's certainly not growing
at some super-healthy clip at least not
until very recently and I think what
that means is it's scared to do anything
that could disturb its growth rate or
just boot a bunch of users off of its
platform and that's led to some of its
most pernicious issues like all of the
trolls the Nazis these people that are
just out there to disrupt the network
and they're basically attacks on Twitter
they're just dragging down the rest of
their network for their own fun and that
comes at a big cost of Twitter because
when you draw I have somebody off of the
platform forever that means you lose all
their ad views and all the content they
create that creates more ad views and so
it's really damaging to Twitter and I
know a lot of people say that oh this is
about free speech that Twitter is just
trying to say oh you can talk about
whatever you want we're not gonna police
Europeans but that's not what's going on
here free speech doesn't mean being able
to shout somebody else down that's
taking speech from somebody by allowing
others to be the bullies and so if
Twitter really cares about free speech
it should care about the speech of the
vulnerable people the ones who are being
attacked by these trolls and should
prioritize their experience over ones
who are desperately trying to drag down
its network so I think Twitter should
just kick off a bunch of those people be
damned whatever happens to the user
metrics and the long term it will be a
healthier safer place that more people
will actually want to join yeah I
watched the interview that a Joe Rogan
did I think he had Tim Poole on he had
Jack Dorsey and then he had I think the
person who runs kind of they're like
policies around all of this and he
really I think did a good job kind of
letting them debate it out
and the one thing I took away from it
was just how complex the ideas are right
and the decisions and one thing I've
appreciated I think about your analysis
has always been like there's two sides
to this story and acknowledging both of
them is important but you can still
prioritize one over the other even if
you recognize that there is another side
of the story right absolutely yeah I
think there's obviously a ton of
complexity and I feel for tech companies
when critics don't offer solutions when
they just say this doesn't work but they
actually don't think through the
consequences of whatever they want to
have happen they don't think about what
would this actually mean not only for
the rest of the user experience not just
the edge cases what it means for the
bottom line and you need to make these
services sustainable so being like I
hate just get rid of all the ads like
that's not an actionable suggestion so I
try to give them them in real ways that
they could fix this so for instance if
they don't want to block all of these
trolls what they should do is make it so
if you don't have a phone number confirm
with your account if you haven't been on
the service for long enough and showed
enough innocent activity they shouldn't
let you reply to strangers and send
notifications to those people if you
have never met this person you have no
proof that you're a good person or the
you're a good actor and you don't even
have a confirm the phone number so they
can't track you and make sure yeah and
actually boot you with any lasting
consequence why should they let you just
barge into somebody else's feed and
experience and yell whatever you want at
them so I think by just controlling
replies a little bit better Twitter
could solve a little a lot of these
problems but again it's just so worried
about disturbing any of its hardcore
users that it's been unwilling to
iterate and evolve yeah it's one of
these things to their historical track
record of changes although highly
controversial when they made them right
so the feed ranking you described kind
of going chronological to ranked also
the number of characters there was
pretty significant backlash like people
forget and I was actually one of the
people going from 140 to 280 being like
oh why are we doing this right and then
once you see is on the other side of it
are like that might been one of the
better decisions they've ever made right
was kind of increasing the character
limit the ranked feed obviously did much
better do you think that these types of
things you're bringing up now or similar
in that there's controversy up front
people fight it but then once you make
it obvious on the back
is everyone kind of agree that was a
good decision yeah over time we've
definitely seen that social networks can
make decisions that users hate at first
but grow to love the Facebook newsfeed
is a perfect example everyone hated when
Instagram went to an algorithmic feed it
actually boosted usage significantly
because suddenly the people who aren't
using these services all the time they
get the best tweets the best posts first
and from the most hardcore users
jimp referencing the entire experience
around those people is gonna make it
really tough to grow long term but that
said I think Twitter has had this
history of deliberating endlessly about
its problems and whenever they do
interviews especially Jack Dorsey he
just dances around every question and he
tries to weigh both sides and he like
gives you all the context but he doesn't
give you decision he doesn't tell you
what actually is needs to happen or
what's gonna change with any real speed
and I think that that is is holding
Twitter back significantly and we've
seen there over time that yes you may
you may prove yourself right over time
but that doesn't mean you can just
ignore user sentiment in the future and
I think that's the lesson that Facebook
has mistaken from all of its experiences
you know ever since the newsfeed blew up
after people originally protested
against it it's basically discounted and
discredited all of the public's
criticism it says I don't know we know
better than you do we like last time we
made a big change you hated it and you
ended up loving it so just bear with us
but time and time again that's led them
into these massive privacy problems
these safety problems I think Twitter is
in the same position now you can't say
that oh just because we made good
decisions in the past that you might not
have liked means that all we should just
ignore everything people say from now on
yeah he's kind of this weird like
black-and-white world right in the sense
of hey I'm not gonna be right all the
time but I do have these data points
that suggests like I'm more right than
wrong and I have data that can prove
that versus admitting like if we're not
gonna be right all the time
what's the framework we decide to use on
when do we listen to data versus when do
we listen to kind of the human critic
and you know I've worked at Facebook etc
and and there's not a good framework for
that most of these companies and so it's
almost one of these questions of like
if you went down that path to explore it
how would you if you're sitting inside
one of the companies think about the
data balanced with the human critic you
know I think you need to think more with
your gut more with your instincts about
what is right as a human being in and
for society because I truly believe that
long-term that's the most value
occurring thing you can do that's what
will actually satisfy Wall Street in the
long term and these tech companies they
often have enough control especially
with Facebook to be able to make their
own decisions somewhat divorced from the
shareholder sentiment and they should be
using that to say hey we're gonna take a
short term profit hits in exchange for a
long term safety and Facebook has
actually made that commitment
while twitter has talked so much about
you know how it you know it really
fights for users and it's better for
political discourse and all this stuff
it has never made a firm financial
commitment to safety it's never made a
firm financial commitment to fighting
misinformation while facebook has
committed billions of dollars to doing
this and it's warned that it's gonna hit
its profits it did hit its profits the
shareholders did definitely dock it for
that but long term if that means
Facebook gets to survive for an extra
five years that accrues so much more
money than just trying to make the
short-term decision and I think
Twitter's been making that short-term
decision for the long term now it spent
years thinking quarter by quarter and
that's why Twitter still has the same
share price it basically did five years
ago which is pathetic for something
that's clearly grown massively in its
value to the public you know what what
about the political ads I know that
that's probably the biggest difference
in approach between Facebook and Twitter
at least a couple of months ago how do
you thought through how both of those
two companies have handled whether the
surface political ads and how they
actually police that stuff now I still
stick with my original opinion which is
that Facebook has to ban political ads
the danger of these is so much greater
than what people are thinking when you
think it a corollary like TV or radio or
billboards those are not the same and
that's why I think Twitter's decision
was actually very bold and very smart
to say we're just not going to allow
political ads it's not worth it for us
you know Facebook's argument has been oh
these political ads they give an advance
to newcomers who or don't have the
advantage of you know already having
tons of media presents you know take the
presidency you know new comers new
Democratic challengers don't get the
same screen time that Donald Trump does
and so the argument is ou allowing
political ads gives these people a
method of growing but that completely
ignores the real safety concern here
which is if you don't police lies in
political ads and you allow political
ads you get this insane flywheel where
somebody can make the most egregious
claim the most scandalous and most
sensationalized idea put it into an ad
and say these people are gonna take your
guns or these people are gonna force
this type of health care situation on
you or oh you you're gonna lose all your
freedoms but only if you donate to me by
midnight tonight I'll match those
donations 5x but just for tonight and
you'll be entered into a contest to win
this thing and all of that can be lies
there can be no deadline there can be no
matching there can be no sweepstakes it
doesn't matter
and especially none of those political
claims even have to be true but they can
instantly cause people to click that
donate button fund more of those ads and
you get this awful flywheel and so
that's why it's different than
television yes
people could lie in television ads but
they couldn't necessarily get people to
donate with a single click and yes there
there were media gatekeepers that could
go in and say yes this is this is what's
going on there's this is wrong this is
inaccurate but now on the Internet these
political pawns can reach their
constituents in the voting base directly
and they don't need those gatekeepers
who are supposed to keep them honest
so without the gatekeepers with them
being able to use wise to raise more
money to buy more ads to spread more
lives
Facebook's decision to allow political
ads and not police them for
misinformation is terribly dangerous for
democracy and this is one of the few
things where I say Twitter has done an
amazing job yeah I think Facebook went
back on it right they're now saying that
they're gonna add some more controls in
place or misremembering so they're only
making very specific exceptions things
for voter suppression and census
suppression and for misinformation that
could immediately cause immediate harm
due to a
around health claims that's where
they're making exceptions and saying
they'll take they'll take away posts or
the police political speech so the
Brazilian president Dr Boston ro he's
been making claims that oh you know we
should all be going back to work and
hydroxychloroquine is gonna solve this
whole crisis of coronavirus and facebook
is saying no that could lead to people
disobeying shelter-in-place orders and
getting sick and so that's direct harm
and so they're taking down those
political statements but it's been
unwilling to do that in America where it
would really face scrutiny for taking
down some of Donald Trump's claims for
instance and I think that if it's not
going to take down if it's not a if it's
gonna allow political ads at all it
needs to get much more serious and much
more expansive about what misinformation
it bans yeah this is probably one of the
greatest debates that I have with
friends is if you're sitting in Twitter
seat specifically what do you do with a
president right Trump is on to the
president now but even future presidents
who use your platform and how do you
draw the line between facts twisting of
like data in facts and then outright
lies and who do you listen to to make
those decisions right and then do you
actually ever get to the point where you
take a president off of your platform do
you shadow ban them like how do you
think through that given the
ramifications for that person is much
bigger the action you take obviously
than if they did it to you or I or just
you know somebody with 10 followers this
is an incredibly complex situation this
is worthy of debate because pretty much
every solution is gonna cause crisis you
know you what you might immediately
think is like well you should stick a
flag on it that says this is
misinformation turns out those flags can
make their supporters feel even more
firmed and sharing them saying oh yeah
like the mainstream media hates this so
we're gonna share this and it draws more
visual attention to these things you
know trying to use fact checks the fact
checks never travel as far as though as
the false information we know that you
see something where you know piece of
false information has hundreds of
thousands of retweets and the correction
gets a few
dozen you know that's not a sustainable
way of addressing this and I think you
did that
trying to algorithmically demote this
kind of content when it happens doing it
kind of secretly these kind of shadow
band new things that's gonna lead to the
kind of confusion and constant claims of
bias that I think are just untenable for
a network to deal with over time that's
why I think Twitter should actually rip
the band-aid off and just say we're
going to completely delete tweets from
politicians that have real-world harm or
that are blatantly blatant
misinformation it should either set up
an independent or acquire or establish a
set of fact checkers that are
independent and are actually unbiased
and when they say something is
misinformation it should just be deleted
and you know what you should do is deal
with the fact that conservative
politicians are gonna lose their minds
they're gonna completely flip out and
say oh this is bias against us but at
some point this is when the techies need
to stand up for what they believe is
right because I think one of the biggest
problems in the political system right
now is that the the technologists the
people who we kind of trust to be
artists the ones who are building the
most advanced if visions of the future
if they don't take a moral stance about
how their technology is used it will be
used for evil and these you know these
people they have enough money they don't
care about the money to be honest most
of these CEOs are so rich that when
people are like oh they're doing this
cuz they want to make more money they
don't care they're literally just too
rich to even care anymore but what they
do like is power they don't want to lose
their power and they're worried that all
their conservative users might abandon
their their network if they do one of
these things but that doesn't mean it's
the right thing to do to just stay
silent and I think at some point these
networks have to stay this is enough is
enough we're gonna shut this stuff off
and say if people are angry about is if
they want to go start a new network or
go leave for another Network that's fine
we're better off without them we want
real honest discourse yeah it's one of
the just most complex issues I think
that face any tech company today is
Twitter specifically with just anyone
who uses their platform the way that the
current president does let's switch
gears a little bit and talk about video
and
in kind of live type components Twitter
has or had at vine obviously and it was
growing it seems pretty good
that got shut down and now tik-tok is
like all the rage what's kind of your
thoughts there I mean the fact that
Twitter had vine it was working it was
popular with the right user base who
were creating content comedians the kind
of culture makers in this country and
they'd even started to add the music
features that tick-tock are now known
for the ability to sort of borrow the
audio from another video or using audio
clips that are designed for perfect
loops like Twitter had it all vine had
it all together and then just because
Jack Dorsey mismanaged the finances of
Twitter you know was running a bit too
tight on cash and was worried about
where did they were spending they just
decided rather than pay for the hosting
costs per vine we're gonna shut it down
and that I think will remain one of
these stupidest decisions in social
networking history because now we've
ceded control to this fundamental piece
of social networking to a Chinese
company which does not share our
country's ideals and values and I mean
the fact is that this product is popular
because it is fun I use tik-tok every
day because it's incredibly entertaining
this concept of micro entertainment that
instead of is autobiographical stories
stuff that we're all getting a bit sick
of it instead of someone spending 15
seconds to shoot something that we spend
15 seconds creating on tick-tock people
spend 2 hours 10 hours creating
something 15 seconds long
- just densify that entertainment and
make it as valuable for your per second
as possible and that's why these
networks are important and why micro
entertainment like Tiktaalik cannot be
easily cloned by Instagram or YouTube or
Facebook which are all building their
own versions Facebook lasso Instagram
has a thing called reels it's testing in
Brazil and just yesterday was revealed
that YouTube is building shorts but the
thing is you need a base of content to
remix in order for these networks to
thrive and any of them starting from
scratch are going to have a really tough
time you can copy all their features the
same way that Facebook copied snapchat
stories and did a very good job it was
very successful with that but with story
you don't need any prerequisite contact
with tick-tock you have to have this
entire corpus of source material that
people can remix in order to make great
content and Facebook and Instagram are
just not going to have that they're
gonna come out of the gate flat-footed
the only hope is that YouTube unlocks
its massive archive of videos you know
the five billion plus videos that people
watch every day and make those available
for remix in their YouTube short SAP and
doesn't you know aggressively apply
Content ID and take down any video that
uses copyrighted sound this is
promotional when somebody puts a song in
a tick-tock that's how will NAS X's Old
Town Road went to the top of the charts
don't take that stuff down so Google
could only succeed here if it
understands that needs to unlock its
database of videos and not police it too
carefully with Content ID yeah the
little NAS X story is incredible for
those they don't know when he basically
did was he created the song and then he
would look for videos or meat or gifts
that were kind of going viral and then
he would basically take that visual put
his song overlaid and then send it to
whoever was posting the original video
that was going viral and say hey use
this one and I think his big break was
he put that song overlay over what is
the doc the guy standing on the horse
like going really fast or something and
then the song blew up with the video and
next thing you know he's you know kind
of this global sensation simply by you
know really hacking together a song with
viral content exactly and that's what
you're not gonna see on these networks
that aren't designed for sort of this
this cross-sharing
the whole the atomic unit of tick-tock
is the remix you take the audio from
somebody else's video you shoot a new
video recontextualizing that joke and
suddenly you have something new without
having to be perfectly creative and
that's the best the real importance here
is you can lower the bar for creating
something truly valuable and watchable
through remixes and that's why I
tick-tock is so powerful and it's why
vine was so great in its era and why
it's gonna be so difficult for even if
Twitter words a we launched mine now it
would be really difficult to catch up
because they don't have that same back
archive of content for remix it yeah it
wasn't there
an issue were like the vine creators all
I got together and I think I remember
reading an article there was like a
showdown between like Twitter management
and a bunch of vine creators living on
Vine Street the apartment or something
right yeah absolutely so you know
Twitter never decided to directly
support vine stars they were not good at
bringing them in-house and sort of
giving them tutorials or helping them
meet the team or use the features they
were not great at connecting them with
brand deals and it just meant that these
vine stars were effectively contributing
all of this content for free and getting
nothing in return and then the next big
wave of social networking is about
monetizing and helping creators monetize
it's not about just slamming people with
ads it's letting the people who make
this content share in the rewards that
they're generating and you know
eventually vine bought my cousin Darren
lachman's startup called niche and
brought it in-house so that it could
help do these deals and connect vine
stars to brands and then Twitter
neglected niche and eventually just sort
of let it wither and this is again this
is like a pioneering establishment in
the influencer marketing world and again
Twitter squandered its opportunity and I
think the fact that you know jack dorsey
has has consistently done this bought
something great like periscope which
have also failed to properly integrate
into the rest of its product and
eventually it really lost that use case
to facebook live that's what everybody
is doing all their live streams of their
concerts is on it's not it's not
periscope it's not Twitter Live it's
Facebook live because Twitter was
unwilling to go all the way and make a
drastic change and integrate periscope
directly into Twitter for so long then
into the same thing with fine and
collecting it and eventually shutting it
down
in the collected niche and I think at
this point you have to wonder does Jack
Dorsey still deserve this job and so
when there's these new corporate raiders
coming in saying if you don't get the
metrics up and do all this and all these
Twitter you know employees are fighting
for him saying oh no he's a great boss
he's a nice guy I've met him he's very
kind he's very empathetic he really
thinks through things but he's not
getting it done and that's what Twitter
needs right now a decisive leader so to
my questions were gonna be to finish the
Twitter part of the conversation 1 do
you think that Twitter is a better
product today than it was three to five
years ago even in spite of all of the
kind of critiques I mean the product is
absolutely better specifically the
algorithmic time line makes it so much
easier to actually find the best stuff
you know the reason Twitter is special
is that it makes any or everybody as
smart as anybody it lets somebody take
all of the research all of the knowledge
all their wisdom from their life use
that as a lens for consuming new
information and then distilling it to
the most important parts that is a
fundamental part of our world
we as a species are so specialized we
all live such different lives and have
such different knowledge that we need a
product like this to be able to all
share in each other's wisdom right and I
think that algorithm timeline does a
great job with that and the 280
character change does help that yeah
sometimes it makes it a little bit
exhausting to read Twitter but it's a
lot less confusing because you're not
trying to read all these things together
just to make a pretty simple point that
said Twitter in the mean time has done
very little to fix its its safety
problems it's allowed them to just run
completely rampant and now when people
think of Twitter they think of getting
attacked they think of the celebrities
that they've heard of like Leslie Jones
who've had to leave Twitter because
they've been so harassed and they just
think of the confusing experience if you
start a new Twitter account today you
will be dumbfounded about how bad the
onboarding experience is they basically
just show you a bunch of celebrities say
follow these people and then dump you on
the timeline they don't teach you
anything about what you should tweet
about how you steal information from the
real world and share it
they don't teach you about digging into
your specific niche interests and
finding the experts in those areas
rather than these totally catch-all no
comp lowest-common-denominator
celebrities and they don't really teach
you about how to interact on the
timeline how replies really work how you
know how any of these different tools
like retweets and favorites tarted they
don't understand it they feel like
they're talking to a black hole because
they do a very bad job of getting new
users followers and they say why am I
doing this
you know Facebook's big metric has
always been how
ask and they get you to 10 friends
because once you have 10 friends your
feed starts getting good and you stick
around Twitter or understood how to
prioritize that onboarding experience
and so it has hundreds of millions of
people who have tried Twitter at some
point and turned away and are now soured
on the platform and are a lot less
likely to ever come back because of this
rotten onboarding experience and so if
there was one thing that the Jack Dorsey
could still do to improve the growth
rate and maybe keep his job or that a
new CEO should come in and prioritize
right away is fix that onboarding
experience make Twitter accessible to
anyone so we can all be as smart as
anyone for sure and the second question
is do you think that the deal with
Silverlake and kind of those corporators
you mentioned etc do you think that
changes anything really or is this more
of what kind of suit the same both
positive and negatives moving forward I
feel unfortunately that it may just
exacerbate the problems that twitter has
had because again now it has to think
even more short-term it can't be even
thinking about next year what Alone's
just thinking about 3 years from now
whether it really should be prioritizing
instead it just has to save its ass
quarter-to-quarter
and i think that that's gonna make
things even worse for twitter and that's
why i don't really and given this crisis
while people might be home doing more on
twitter and they might be spending more
time there the entire social networking
advertising space is taking a massive
hit huge companies like Airbnb and
Marriott have said we're just not
advertising we're not doing any
marketing anymore and that is going to
directly affect the bottom line of these
companies so I feel it's very unlikely
that Jack Dorsey is gonna hit his
metrics and be able to keep his job and
you know maybe that's for the best
I don't really think of corporate
raiders as generally being better at
prioritizing long term growth but I
don't know it can get a lot worse than
what Jack's been doing talking about
tick-tock in YouTube what you mission
the security concerns around tick-tock
but you think you still use the product
kind of walk me through like what what
do you think is real in those security
concerns what I mean by that is I think
that tic TOCs one of these weird things
where there's actually a lot of
controversy and people
you can't promote different talk tracks
around it but nobody really knows what's
going on I feel like you of all people
would have best you don't Matt how do
you look at the security concerns there
I mean at the end of the day you have to
understand the tick tock is owned by
bite dance the China's from a most
valuable private company right now and
we just don't really know what's going
on inside of it you know we don't mean
what we do know is that they really
don't have America's best interests in
mind in general and so you know what
you're going to experience is this
uncertainty about where your data is
going and when it comes to moderation
you also have the worry that you know
China and tick tock can be influencing
the global moderation standards for tick
tock and saying here's what we do and
don't want on the app and there's been
instances where people saying you know
criticizing the Chinese government of
some or have suddenly had their you know
their account suspended in the no tick
tock once it becomes a big media scandal
they say oh that was an accident we
didn't mean to do that
but and I now take talks trying to set
up this you know this moderation board
and you know these these transparency
measures to try to tell people and
explain what's going on with the
algorithm but at the end of the day the
company is still owned by by a Chinese
Giants it has not shown that it's
willing to make fair choices for the
globe or be able to you know sort of
follow in line with what we imagine is
being free speech and how speech should
be regulated and so I do think it's
reasonable that Cepheus the government's
regulator that looks at foreign
investment is considering whether the
the acquisition of tick-tocks and of
musically which was another Chinese
company but have operated largely in the
u.s. that when they acquire when music
or when take stock acquired musically
and merge it in and it became the
tic-tock we know today whether that
should be undone in hopes that it might
give a chance for an American competitor
maybe Instagram Rios maybe Facebook
class oh maybe YouTube shorts maybe even
vine coming back to life or white which
is started by one of the vine founders
to give them a chance at owning this
social entertainment use case so you
know I'm not I'm not worried enough that
every day I'm under that I'm just going
to block
good delete tik-tok entirely from my app
but that said I wouldn't use the the
face swap feature that it that it was
testing in China which makes you do like
the full volumetric scan of your face
the way that you unlike a setup face ID
on your iPhone don't give that scan to
any company you don't trust and you know
they're not doing that in the US yet and
I broke the news that they were testing
and prototyping this but there are
certain things certain types of
biometric data you never want to give to
anyone because that's going to be the
thumbprint of the future yeah it's
pretty scary when you realize it's kind
of the 23andme and all the DNA testing
it's the the Trojan horse of hey we can
tell you you know where your family's
from or we can tell you this or that and
then next thing you know
oh wait that got shipped out to another
country or it's being sold to people etc
I think people get very nervous about
that I'm just calling it out early and
often super important there YouTube what
do you actually put there the odds of
success with things for YouTube shorts
so you know that YouTube has stories I
did not know that yeah nobody knows that
because they did such a bad job at it
that YouTube has become such an
expansive and bloated app that it's very
difficult for it to launch significant
new features that aren't right in the
center of its existing experience you
know we can modify the recommendation
algorithm and that will have massive
effects but you know any feature that's
not just what you already know YouTube
to be is gonna be so buried that you're
never gonna find it so nobody knows or
really uses YouTube stories and
similarly with shorts shorts is going to
be designed to be another sub feed of
the app sort of another buried feature
and so unless it's willing to go all out
the way that Instagram did with stories
Instagram didn't put stories in a
separate tab which you'd never check it
stuck them right at the top of the
screen unless YouTube's willing to make
a bold enough bet on shorts and put it
right on the home screen it's never
going to take off and on top of that it
will have to make a bunch of smart
policy decisions about how to unlock its
archive of remixable of content how not
to apply Content ID and do really
brilliant in an influencer outreach to
get all these people started and say hey
did you miss the boat with tik-tok we
got a new bow
what other areas of consumer or social
are you either paying attention to or
excited about that you think people
should or should be aware of the two
base areas I think are really
fascinating in social right now are
calendaring and offline meetups
and then those are kind of connected and
so specifically there's a few companies
like ones called Saturn which is a
calendar designed for teenagers and
another is it's called IRL which I just
wrote about today and IRL is an event
discovery platform and calendar which
makes it easy to figure out what's going
on around you set up plans to do it with
the friends or come up with a new plan
like hey let's let's have a Netflix
watching party and then set a soon date
and then figure it out with your friends
in an in-app chat you know it's trying
to make the calendar social in a way
that it hasn't been before
well Saturn is for high school students
and helps them share their classes and
class notes it's basically becoming kind
of a professional linked in esque tool
but for high schoolers and I think both
of those are really fascinating and IRL
actually you know it was about in real
life today it pivoted to be in remote
life because we can't really go to any
events it's like imagine being a startup
where you just help people discover real
world events and then it becomes illegal
to go to real world events like that is
a death knell for most startups but they
were smart to really quickly adapt to
the change lean into it and and pivot to
being all about discovering live streams
of concerts educational classes eSports
tournaments and stuff like that so I
think that's really fascinating is the
idea that a lot of these we're gonna
just basically take the social
components that we know exists on other
platforms and just overlay that on the
actual calendar is that the general
premise yeah that's part of it it's
about you taking what is really too
deeply bundled into Facebook and that
Facebook has largely ignored and make it
into something a standalone product
that's really really high utility and
really simple and so yeah with IRL
whether it's about getting you to be
able to watch a live stream with friends
or actually meet up at a coffee shop or
go to the park together you know it's
trying to figure out an offline
availability indicator you know that's
something that we don't have you have a
green dot on all your chat apps that let
people know when you're on the chat
but you don't have a green dot to say
hey I'm just home by myself doing
nothing right now I'd love to get dinner
or I'd love to do a workout together or
I'd love to go watch something on
Netflix you know and I think that that's
a really massive area for innovation
which could make us a lot less alone
you know uh you know I think a lot of us
if any of you have these college
experience where you know your doors
were always open in the dorm and you can
just walk around and see what other
people were up to and spontaneously make
plans as we grow into adults we put all
these walls and doors between us and it
suddenly becomes a lot tougher to have a
spontaneous social interaction and it
can feel really awkward and kind of
depressing if you reach out directly to
a bunch of prints and what are you doing
tonight you want to hang out you want to
go get dinner you want to watch a movie
or something and nobody responds or
everyone's like oh no I'm busy I've got
plans it's really discouraging and so
these apps need to figure out a way to
make that more passive show my friend
that Oh looks like josh is free so that
they can reach out to me if they wanted
rather than me having to do that work
and expend my social capital and feel
awkward when I get rejected yeah it's
super interesting it's like every couple
I know they all manage their joint life
together via Gmail the G calendar right
it's just like hey look we've got a
shared calendar I can see what you've
got going on you can see what I've got
going on and so being able to bring that
to a wider audience than just a kind of
a party of two I think makes a lot of
sense but it also overlays with what you
said kind of a second component of just
offline events in general what's kind of
the thesis there or what has you excited
about that I'm just excited about the
idea that you know we spend so much of
our time staring at a screen and most of
these apps they monetize by getting you
to stare even deeper into that screen
and I think the next wave of social apps
you know zenlea which isn't a product
that was acquired by snapchat snapchat
Sohn snap map things like IRL the real
opportunity is to say get people offline
get them to have real interactions
together in person those are the things
we remember those are the memories that
we cherish and if you want to add value
to someone's life I think that's the
easiest way to do it like if you can't
meet up offline there's a whole new wave
of apps that are helping people hang out
online and that's around screen sharing
so specifically there's an app called
[ __ ]
which is blowing up right now I think
it's at like number 15 on the AppStore
charts all of a sudden it's rocketing up
the charts after launching last year and
basically it just lets a few people
screen share together so one person can
be scrolling Instagram all the other
people comment or you can be you know
debating a tinder profile and saying oh
should I swipe right or swipe left and
it basically creates the same kind of
experience that many of us had growing
up hanging out in parking lots and
basements where you weren't really doing
anything you weren't like going to a
place spending money doing a like a
planned event you're just Co hanging out
and we haven't had a core layer for that
online and now we finally have one which
is this screen sharing you don't have to
be in the same room to basically just be
hanging out and you don't even have to
be actively talking I think what we have
is this big wave of live-streaming
but most people don't want to be the
center of attention on camera for a
sustained period of time nor do they
have enough to say or do or to show off
to actually be entertaining and so you
know things like a house party made it
easier for people to Alton so that it's
more about group video chat nobody's the
center of attention everyone's just
chatting at once but screen sharing
takes it to the next level where nobody
even has to be on camera you can both
just be sharing your screens not looking
at each other's faces but laughing and
joking around together and occasionally
talking and you know fortnight has
similarly created a role for that for
young men and I think apps like squad
which has a female CEO and amazing woman
named Esther Crawford has an opportunity
to do that more for for young women as
well as everybody yeah it's really
interesting actually the live-streaming
component if you look at many of the
largest live streamers they're things
like gamers etc and basically what they
would do is definitely talking about
so whereas most people would try to use
live streaming for shorter periods of
time and like hey let me entertain you
these folks who in the gaming industry
would just login they'd be on for eight
to ten hours they play video games and
just like passively hang out with
whoever was there and kind of talk and
and all of those things that you would
do in like the basement you know years
ago they actually ended up being some of
the best live streamers and built the
biggest audiences etc and so it's unique
how maybe the people who are the best at
using these tools actually use it in a
different way than kind of the majority
of folks who you know got boxed into
thinking like this is just like a short
vscreen almost and I should think this
is really important for mental health I
don't know about you did you ever spend
long periods of time on the phone with
your male friends growing up never I
didn't either
now suddenly boys can sit together on
fortnight for hours just chatting about
their life because they have the
plausible distraction of oh we're
shooting people so weird this is clearly
manly this is there's no affront to my
own masculinity they can feel
comfortable and you know that's I think
that's really productive because a lot
of young men have a lot of feelings they
need to get out and they don't have
other outlets for them and so creating a
channel where they can talk about it
without having be like hey buddy I need
to have like a really hard conversation
with you which might be a bit daunting
instead it could just be like hey we've
been playing for a night for an hour I
was like hey man this girl actually
broke my heart like what do you think I
should do like that's the kind of
conversation that I think we all need to
have more oh we need to have more of
those vulnerable real conversations with
our close friends and any product
whether that's a game my fortnight
whether that's a screen sharing app like
like squad or whether it's getting
people together offline they can app
like IRL you know that is a great thing
for destroying loneliness making people
happy or making people feel less
isolated
and that's critical especially now yeah
so a lot of what we've talked about so
far is what I'll call more like personal
and social components of our lives
obviously given the the quarantine we've
kind of seen the world thrust into in
the professional world like the whole
remote work vertical and so things like
zoom slack you know etc role ticking off
in usage I think the zoom numbers they
just reported was like 10 million da use
and ninety days later they're not 200
million which is just mind-boggling
growth what are you seeing in kind of
the more professional side of all this
communication and live streaming or
video chats etc
yeah I've been Zumba and zooming zoom is
just blown up and blown up literally
with zoom bombing which is this term I
coined a few weeks ago and now it's
being cited by the FBI and by Eric on
the the CEO of zoom as you know this
problem of people you know just
searching out for URLs of zoom calls and
jumping into them and disrupting them or
screen-sharing awful you know two girls
one cup and awful porn things to be
screens and really offending people you
know it's clear that these enterprise
apps have suddenly have to had to adapt
to social use cases but I think the
other the opposite direction is what's
making the enterprise products so much
better we're seeing a lot of them
embrace a lot of this the consumer
social Tropes
and making themselves a lot less
friction 'full a lot less complicated
and just really focusing on the you know
the interaction the human interaction
rather than all the chrome surrounding
it and so one of the two of the apps I
think are really fascinating in this
space are loom and around they're both
the enterprise video-chatting products
but unlike a big square like zoom you
know with with loom you record short
little video clips and then send them to
your co-workers and then they can watch
them and they can quickly send them back
and they do a really good job of Auto
processing the footage and uploading it
before you had finished it so you can
really go back and forth it's like a
video walkie-talkie for the office and
that's actually a lot more productive
than just being constantly connected
like you can be on slack where you're
just always talking or zoom if anybody's
spent the last few weeks not getting any
work done yet having nonstop soon calls
you know that one on one or like group
video chat can be very distracting to
your work if it's just constantly going
and taking up so much or your screen
whereas loom just wants you to pop in
and out around is another enterprise
video product and this one I think is
especially brilliant it basically turns
your co-workers into tiny little bubbles
that like rest across your screen and
they overlay on the top of the rest of
your screen and so rather than you
having to have a big window open with
zoom that covers up your other work and
you're sort of struggling to juggle apps
and tabs to be able to have enough space
to actually get something done around
just hovers over the top of your desktop
and lets you just instantly chat with
people whenever you want and it makes it
really easy it's almost like being in
the same office together where you're
not constantly talking but you can be
like hey and then and that's I think it
was a really good use case is thinking
about how these offline products and how
our offline behaviors work and how you
can more faithfully convert them into a
digital experience one more I think is
really cool it's called screen that's a
new screen sharing tool by the guy who
cut crea
screen hero and sold it to slack he
didn't think slack did a good enough job
of integrating it so we left him rebuilt
the company it's called screen and it
lets you do collaborative screen sharing
where everybody gets their own cursor
and everybody can affect everything so
it's like Google Docs for all apps you
can Co code together you can you know
debate designs together and all like
move things around you can do ephemeral
drawings and text over the top to label
and annotate things it's actually like
all staring at one screen huddled around
together I think that's really good yeah
one of the things I keep going back to
think through is the three things you
just described all three of those
companies they're almost like a version
of a are right where basically you have
like this shared experience there's
overlays we can interact and it's
probably not the AR that I think we all
initially thought that we would adopt
with like the glasses overlaid on the
real world being you know the physical
world but to me like there are a lot of
similarities here and I wonder can we
get AR adopted and kind of people
familiar with it on the screen and then
eventually that brings it into the
physical world you seek any of the
corollaries there holy that's actually
really smart concept I hadn't thought of
is that you know if you think of virtual
reality as taking over your whole screen
and augmented reality is only being a
little bit of the screen overlaid on
your life similarly you could think of
as zoom as being the virtual reality and
while something like around is augmented
reality it's overlaid on the rest of
your screen rather than trying to take
up the whole thing and yeah I think we
may be able to grow more comfortable
with those augmented reality experiences
contained within a screen then and we
have the hardware to do it already then
we're gonna be able to for quite a while
in the real world you know the fact is
that augmented reality Hardware for for
like eyewear is still a ways away
you know snapchat CEO Evan Spiegel
thinks it's gonna be ten years till it's
mainstream magically it seems to think
it's gonna be now but that company I
think is destined to go out of business
or be sold in a fire sale because
there's just no way there's just not use
cases like nobody has given me a
compelling reason why I should walk
around like this all day and any product
that can't do selfies or video chat how
is that the future like I don't really
see that being the future
for quite a while I think the fact that
we have this cool device that's um
actually on an Auto stabilized six axis
gimbal is like it's a pretty good way to
interact with technology in the real
world yeah it almost feels like AR and
VR still got to go through the evolution
that lunar the phones did or even like
take headphones right we're like it got
closer and closer to us and got smaller
and smaller and so eventually you get
something like an air pod right or you
get the ability to use the iPhone etc it
just felt like people tried to jump from
like non-existent AR VR so like what we
all think the final state is and now
what we're realizing is like hey there's
got to be that evolution that's how you
get the user comfortable using it
because there are you know magically at
least some of the demos that I've seen
that combine there was one where I saw
like the heart beating right it was kind
of this virtual heart and you could walk
around it and do all the stuff it's like
that's cool but like when would I ever
use that right maybe if I was like a
doctor like an ER doctor okay but that's
a pretty small use case for that
specific application and so I just don't
know if people are really comfortable
with this stuff ya know I think we're
gonna see a augmented reality for the
enterprise for the workplace long before
it becomes consumer ready because in the
workplace you don't have to look Kerry
if you care if you look dorky right it
doesn't matter if you've got a big weird
thing on your head you're being paid for
it so it's okay or there's some sort of
weird edge use case that you know you
know you're gonna do every single day
day in and day out so it makes sense to
wear a helmet that helps you do it but
in our day to day consumer lives our
patterns are always changing we're
always doing different things we're vain
we care about how you look we don't want
to be uncool and so I just don't really
see something usurping the phone anytime
soon it might be a toy it might be good
for gamers it might have some very
specific use cases you know for
influencers or live streamers but I
don't think it's going to be something
we're all going to be using anytime soon
yeah I'm gonna ask you what you think
your best or a favorite AR VR experience
has been but while you're thinking of
what that is I don't know if you've seen
I think it's Google Images you can like
Google a tight
or bear or something and then basically
open the camera and it will put a VR
image of a tiger or a bear like in your
living room or in your kitchen and it's
cool for kids right like you or I may do
it to show our friend one time it's not
something that I'm doing on a daily
basis or have really kind of utility for
other than hey this is cool but I do
think that those are like small steps in
the right direction any idea what like
the best AR VR experience that you that
you've seen is the best VR experience by
far is the stuff that you can't actually
do at home I think the concept of the VR
arcade is destined to have a real
lifespan you know company he's like
sandbox VR and the void VR those are
really awesome ones where it's like
mixed reality experience you put on all
their hardware you go to a real live
place you and your friends all get to do
it together
you play these expansive games they have
this concept of mists directive walking
you've never heard of this this is the
most mind-blowing thing ever
so with mr. active walking you can put
people in a big circular track imagine
like a 50 meter diameter like track and
it's a circle but in the VR headset they
crook it so it makes it look straight
and so what basically happens is by
adjusting your view very slightly they
actually act like baby they subtly trick
your brain into walking slightly left
and so you walk in a circle when you're
thinking you're walking straight and it
lets you create these very expansive VR
experiences where you think you've
walked a mile and you're in like a tiny
warehouse it's really brilliant so those
are fun vote the void in sandbox B are
my favorite VR experience today is
called birdly you strapped into an
animatronic table with giant wooden
wings and you basically you lay on this
flat table in the robe the robotic arms
of it like lift your legs up and when
you tip your wings forward you're you're
a bird in VR and you actually dive and
it whips your feet up behind you and it
cranks up a fan in your face and it
really feels like flying I tried this I
think five years ago at Sundance and
it's still my favorite VR experience it
was the only one worth when they took me
out I said no don't make me go back to
be a bird and like they just there was
they dog dragged me out of this VR
experience and
yeah the arcades are gonna be a thing
especially for you embodying those
fantasies that many of us have like
flying in augmented reality I can't say
that there's some experience that when I
think about it it's like wow that really
blew my mind and made my life better
I've gone to Sundance
year after year and tried out a bunch of
their experiences magic leap and all
this other stuff you know I've seen some
interesting stuff with the augmented
reality art galleries where you have an
empty room but there's all these giant
art pieces that you can like walk around
and explore and I think there's
definitely use cases for for like maps
and being able to pull up hidden
information but I think that a phone
works just fine for that and you know I
tried the newest version of snapchat
spectacles they over like on video later
you can overlay these sort of real world
augmented reality effects they don't
it's a joke it's a toy it's it's not
that cool and so you know until people
come up with those killer use cases
there's no way people are buying any art
they are hardware yeah I tend to agree
that uh it'll come and it's just gonna
take some time what um what are your
thoughts on a Bitcoin and crypto III
don't know how much you you've looked
into it but what's your general thoughts
there you know I think we're in this
this moment with crypto and
decentralized finance and D apps where
it's about usability you know we got
this early adopter base these developer
base these people were really into code
and Finance to adopt crypto and we had
that massive spike you know about a year
and a half ago but there's been the sort
of trough of disillusionment since and I
think that's because it's really
difficult for most mainstream people to
use crypto you know powered experiences
or decentralized apps they require
complex browsers and you know these
really long cryptographic keys that
nobody can remember you know stitching
together all these different tools and
you know what we really need is
something that's more like facebook
login but for crypto we need something
that makes it really easy for me to
bring all of my crypto assets all of my
my identity wherever I go and instantly
log into these experiences you know
there's companies like bits key which is
trying to build this kind of login layer
and usability layer for for the crypto
in decentralized app space
I think you know there's there's other
people who are trying to build stuff
like this to coin bases in that space of
like log in with coin base that kind of
idea I think until that usability
arrives and until we can say here's not
only a use case for Twitter but it's a
easily usable use case that's when
you're gonna finally get the mainstream
adopting it and I think we're gonna see
prices increase again yeah it's really
interesting because if you actually
think about what's the most
user-friendly experience it's like
buying the crypto assets right so it's
getting on a coin base to Gemini
whatever and actually just buying it
once you get past that very simple
action it's incredibly difficult in the
example that I always used when talking
to people is like we're still sending to
wallet addresses that look like random
strings of letters and numbers and until
that gets solved there's just an entire
population of users that I think can't
come into the space so I think that
you're generally spot-on there do you
see the large tech companies moving more
into the space obviously Facebook's got
Libra and what they're doing there what
do you see kind of from the big tech
intersection here
I feel like trying to do something
really big and ambitious has been pretty
well dissuaded by libras reaction I
can't imagine any company like Google or
Amazon especially anybody with any
antitrust concerns who's already having
problems who's trying to sort out which
of their other bets to focus on that
they're gonna dive into this space it's
become very clear that regulators are
not gonna allow tech giants to do
something that has the level of power
the level of scope that would be
necessary for it to be this insane win
for their businesses you know in a lot
of cases a lot of what you know Facebook
wanted to do with Libra can be done with
other type of visions of its payment
technology it's like yeah people want to
be able to do remittance easily people
want to be able to you know buy and sell
things without the same credit card
transaction views I think those are
really smart goals for crypto but I
don't think necessarily trying to
replace the currency we had currently
use is the way to do that if so it's
like lettin Facebook do that on the back
end let me pay real money it does the
crypto transfer in Libra on both sides
and then spits out us
on the other side as well like that
would be so much more comprehensible for
the regulator's to accept then then what
it's trying to do with Libra and so I
think it's not necessary for these big
tech companies to launch things like
that I think they're much more
interested in launching their own credit
cards their own financial services that
I play with the traditional financial
system because that's where the real
money is being made because there's not
the same usability issues yeah and is it
almost every one of these companies is
gonna have to go into FinTech right like
they have the advertising they've got
like all the models they currently have
but it just feels like each one of
whether it's Google its Facebook Apple
etc they're all just slowly making
progress into this space and some of
them are doing it direct like obviously
Apple with the apple cart etc is like a
direct shot into finance but even some
of the other companies trying to
introduce like POS and things like that
just are they all having to go to that
space yeah I think the the old trip was
that every app eventually becomes a
messaging app and now it's like every
app eventually becomes a finance app
it's just because that's where the money
is being made when you move a ton of
money around some of it inevitably falls
off the truck and into your pocket and I
think that that's why you know that's
why the banking sector makes so much
money they've been creating a lot of
value they're just moving the money
around and somehow a bunch of it ends up
in their pockets and so I think that
same reason these tech companies are
gonna get into it more and more you're
already seeing interesting plays in this
space
things like clear Bank which will take
your your stripe and your Facebook Ads
accounts analyze them and say hey you're
worthy of a much better priced loan than
you can get from a bank because we know
you're actually selling things and every
dollar we give you you earn three
dollars back and so they can give you
these loans so I wouldn't be surprised
to see more more businesses more tech
giants getting into that phase then
things like patreon are creating funds
to sort of fund the initial content
creation set up for creators and I think
you'll see that too you know one of the
latest Y Combinator companies is
actually a loan system for influencers
where they can say hey look at all the
money that I'm making on my on my
sponsored content posts give me a loan
so that I can buy a better
camera I can hire a photographer then
I'll make even more money off my
following and I wouldn't be surprised to
see people like twitch and YouTube start
to get into that influence or financing
space and then of course you've got
things like Robin Hood that are trying
to expand into all types of lending and
services but anybody who deals with
small businesses as we've seen with
square and there's an opportunity to get
into that financing space these tech
giants have tons of cash on hand they're
not doing anything with it it'd be
better for them to invest it through one
of these models and make a higher return
than just sitting on it so if you've got
a ton of cash and you got a ton of users
you may as well turn into a finance
company yeah I want to finish up you
mentioned kind of the influencers and
content creators and to me this is like
one of the most interesting places in
tech and it sounds weird saying that
because it's not actually technology in
many cases it's like the users of the
technology I mean especially when you
get to the marketplaces where like the
content creators are providing one half
of the market in the content they create
what do you see changing there right so
like you talked a little bit about maybe
how they finance their operations and
things like that but what are you kind
of seeing there or looking at over the
next couple of months I mean to date
most of the financing for creators has
been through advertising it's either
been through an ad split like YouTube
does where they give you a piece of the
revenue from ads that run near your
content or there's a there's through
sponsored content where influencers
arrange their own deals induce or
product placement and things like that
the next wave is certainly tipping and
subscription patronage where all of
these platforms are going to get a lot
more serious about letting you paid you
know a one-time fee to a creator to be
able to say you know to to highlight
yourself in a livestream chat or get a
special badge or get some kind of
message or come communication with them
things like cameo are allowing people to
pay for direct interaction with the
influencers and I think that like
subscriptions like patron patreon are
gonna become more common across the
space because people forget when they
subscribe and pay for things and so they
end up just paying a lot more money so
it's it's good for creators and it's
probably good for these platforms as
well the next thing I think is really
important though is merchandise because
whenever you're talking about digital
experiences you're still talking about
the longtail all of these fans who might
be willing to pay
dollar two or maybe $5 a month or
something but the real money is in
monetizing the wheels the gaming
industry understands this they make a
ton of their money the majority of their
money off of at any fraction of their
users who are just total hardcore
addicts if you will we're just buying
every in app purchase and you know I
actually used to work for Bon Jovi
running all of his ticketing merchandise
websites fan clubs and the way the Bon
Jovi made his money was on $3,500 to
front-row seat packages that came with a
sign program you have got flip cam with
it I'm dating myself
you got a flip camera in it you maybe
got a back backstage experience but it
was about monetizing these whales his
super fans and selling the most super
high priced products and that's why I
think the next big phase of influencer
monetization is in merchandise and sort
of either offline or online personal
one-to-one experiences because people
want to have memories with these
creators they don't want to just watch
them they want to be part of their lives
too they want they want them to notice
me senpai you know they want to be part
of it and that's why I think cameo is a
great idea and I think you might end up
seeing companies like Facebook and
Twitter and YouTube adopt a cameo esque
option where it's like are you watching
this person's video pay $50 in schedule
a two minute phone call with them I
think that's gonna be really popular and
I think merchandise selling large ticket
item large price sort of collectors
items that these creators are making I
think that will be a huge space
especially because they already have the
interaction with their fans to be able
to ami test these different options for
what kind of merch they want in fact one
of the smartest things they can do is
say hey here's three different t-shirt
options I'm considering vote for the one
you like best and then they make the one
that gets the most votes and then a lot
of people that voted for it they feel
like they were part of the creation
process they want a momento of that
interaction and they buy that shirt for
sure and so I think all of these
platforms are gonna need to embrace
merchandise not just being like actively
a Shopify store but working with them
directly the same way we have influencer
relations which teach influencers how to
best use the digital tools we're gonna
have merchandise representatives that
help them create their own brand in the
physical world that helps them train
translate their online personality into
offline objects and sell them for a lot
more than they're making in tiny little
$1.00 tips yeah it's a it's really
interesting because when you layer in
the subscriptions like I've been using
some stack for a long time and the
second you get out of like the ad model
and you get into the kind of audience
funded model it really does change the
way that you think about it as a
business right you'd have to worry about
pleasing average Heiser's you spend zero
time talking to advertisers and you also
have this sense of like like [ __ ]
everybody else right like I can do I can
do whatever I want because the people
that are paying me I'm doing it for them
so it's really interesting how that
changes when it comes to like these
superfans though do you see any
companies that are really helping
creators do that yet so like the Bon
Jovi type thing whether it's digital or
you know in-person you know we've seen a
few of the companies that have been in
this space kind of get acquired or you
know not really hit their full potential
so no way you know one of them got
acquired by patreon came in house to
help them with their merchandise
operations and so patreon is definitely
a leader in this space they're thinking
a lot about how to do merch Spotify to
their credit eventually did do things
where you can now buy merch and see
those kind of options right on an artist
page and I think the streaming music
companies have enormous influence in
this space you know especially for
anybody who's in the music industry
you know these streaming companies are
the main connection between an artist
and a fan and I would be surprised if
Spotify doesn't get more serious about
selling that access selling direct
messaging to those users so that people
can sell more content you know modifies
like hey rather than putting up a
billboard which is like maybe Ricci has
like a 1% hit rate of actually hitting
your target audience why not buy a
billboard inside of Spotify which is
only shown to your biggest fans
and every time they click you're gonna
make money you know I think that that's
that kind of a model is going to be more
and more popular so anybody who has a
large social graph anybody who has a big
following
I think these platforms are gonna help
them directly contact and sell things to
their their fans better you cameo is
obviously a big one you know the back
I think they may have their breakout
moment this week because they're selling
access to the tiger king cast you can
get like the tiger king cast members to
send your friend like an insane message
or video call and like I can't think of
a better use than $50 right now then
just like blowing up my group chat with
a personalized meme from one of the
tiger king cast members you know I think
that that's that's gonna become
increasingly popular but even things
like Facebook they just widen their
star's platform which shows their their
online tipping platform and so now
instead of just for gamers that's going
to other types of influencers as well so
they're getting into it periscope and
Twitter has their their own method but
you know everybody is going to need
tools for this that are sort of platform
agnostic and so I think there's room for
independent startups to come in and be
the tool for this that works across all
of the social platforms helped you get
your the word out about your merchandise
or your offline experiences or your
phone calls with people so their entire
fanbase
and if anybody's out there looking for a
start-up idea I think that's a really
good one yeah my favorite use of cameos
so far as I just saw that somebody hired
or paid for remember the woman that was
in that peloton had created a message
for the peloton short sellers so they
basically had her like say hey you know
who better to deliver this message than
me total times not going anywhere and I
said you know look at if if you get a
couple more kind of like these
commercials that go viral like that one
did you can immediately see those actors
or actresses then turning around and
basically almost becoming like pseudo
spokespeople for the company and
something like cameo could easily help
facilitate yeah absolutely
especially given that people now can
have livestream now like I'm surprised I
haven't seen anybody just doing
back-to-back-to-back cameo calls
well what live streaming the whole
experience of their entire audience and
just being like yo let's see what crazy
person I have to talk to you next and
just like going at it yeah absolutely
alright man listen I really appreciate
you doing this last few questions to
finish up and then you get to ask me one
question the best book you've ever read
sorry not written read I think
uh Hermann Hesse's Steppenwolf was
really important to me when I was
growing up this book is about what it's
like to feel animalistic to feel caged
in society which i think is more
relevant now than ever
you know just feeling totally boxed in
and claustrophobic in your own skin and
trying to determine what is it that
really matters in life and the real
answer is following your instincts and
being yourself and finding a way to turn
your passion into a profession and I
think that's what so many of our
generation are really trying to figure
out right now is how do I not sell my
soul to the corporates how do I not
become this with this lifeless drone how
do I make what I care about a big part
of my life and Steppenwolf is really all
about that story so that's one that I
really loved yeah I love that answer
people who read a lot or a well read
think about that question a lot they
they don't have a one right off the top
of their head so it's cool to see that
that's what will you remember aliens
believer non-believer think they're real
so I say one more time
aliens think that they're real um I
think yes I do think aliens exist
somewhere in the the greater galaxy do I
think that we're gonna interact with
them anytime soon no in our lifetime
likely not you know the universe is just
extraordinarily vast and there's all
those very good reasons why it might not
happen you know they don't want to
disturb us you know the anyone that
reaches out and sort of makes contact
ends up getting destroyed you know I'm
really hoping that the whatever these
aliens are you would imagine that the
technological advancement would make
them peaceful because when you gain
technological advancement you eventually
gain abundance and you have no scarcity
why do you need to steal or take from
other people or be aggressive unless
there's some sort of like global or I'm
sorry intergalactic religious orthodoxy
where they say if you don't follow our
special leader then then we don't want
anything to do with you that's maybe my
biggest existential fear for the entire
earth is that if that that's the one way
technological advancement could be
defeated is through orthodoxy yeah I
ever seen in response to the virus I
don't know if we're ready to deal with
any sort of alien contact
right now especially if they're coming
here yeah I think they're probably gonna
just do a u-turn as soon as they see
what's going on on this planet cool Mia
what's the what's the one question you
have for me to finish up you know I
would really want to ask what does it
feel like to be someone who influences
people's finances because this is
something that's so core to their life
but you actually leave people to have
great wins or maybe great losses and you
know that can be weigh on someone and so
I want to know what you know what does
it feel like in its best of times and
its worst of times yeah it's a fantastic
question
so this this is that we've changed
a time in a weird way of like I didn't
early on have any influence I actually
had you know like 500 followers or
whatever and it over time as you kind of
gain a larger and larger following it
takes a while to actually realize that
you have any influence and then there's
like certain moments like I look back on
his bike five or six more like Oh like
okay that was like a level up from where
I thought I was and so what you actually
learned is there's two components to it
one is you become much more responsible
so like I could say things when I had
five hundred followers that would be
like offhand comments that I wouldn't
think about but now if I said it people
would be like you know he's basically
giving advice so there's a lot of caveat
eing and like kind of like disclosures
almost right I feel like I'm like
reading like fine print almost when I
talk about certain things so that's like
a little weird and then the second thing
is I've become much more cynical and I
think it's because what I see is like
literally today I've probably gotten
three or four DMS on Twitter like one of
them was some guy asked me hey is this
your Instagram account they're DMing me
asking me to set up a digital wallet to
send money
so like scam account then to is like hey
have you heard of this person and they
show me somebody on Twitter who's
literally running scams right as like
financial advice and then three is like
what do you think about this product or
that product and what you quickly
realize is like one the lack of
education right people just don't know
and actually want to learn and they want
to understand but they just don't know
and so they end up making bad decisions
because they have like bad data but then
the second thing is you get to this
world where you have to understand that
like I'm not here to tell people what to
do what I'm here to do is give them the
information and hopefully present it in
a way where like this is how you should
contextualize the information on this
ultimately have to have responsibility
for the decisions you make and I think
that when you take when you get to that
point then it becomes less about like
hey Josh you should do X with your money
and instead it comes to hey Josh this is
why I'm doing what I'm doing with my
money if you have questions are gonna
happy to answer for you but at the same
time like you've got to make your own
decisions and here's all of the risks
and all of the potential benefits but
like you have to be like responsible for
yourself
I just don't know if our society's like
ready for that world like we're in such
a world of like I want to blame
everybody else for anything that goes
wrong but when things go right I want to
take all the credit myself that just
like ownership of this is like a really
weird time to kind of see that coming to
play yeah I've had to grapple with that
as a journalist myself and you know I've
taken a different take on it which is
that you know if I do all the research
if I have all the context I talk to
people I get the unda stilled version I
get the unabridged version and then I'm
giving people the abridged version the
sort of the crib notes if I don't give
them some subjective direction of what I
think is right then I'm effectively
cheating them out of all the excess
information I couldn't cram into the
article everything that I couldn't
crystallize and I would hope that given
in the current state of things people
can are free to follow and listen to
whoever they want and if so if they
don't believe in my subjective takes on
it they can find someone they do but if
I'm not giving them that subjective take
in the first place I feel like I'm
really cheating them out of something
and given we're in a place where being
just sort of totally neutral doesn't
work with technology because technology
just absorbs whatever the morals are of
the people who are the most forceful
with it and so if left to people those
were the worst incentives the greed the
lust for power those are the ones that
are going to shape what technology is
but so I think those of us and as I
think of you as one of these people who
really does have empathy for the world
who wants to see things go better you
know as my mission statement and
personally is to like help the world
more gracefully adapt to the future I
think people like us have to be willing
to take a subjective stand point the
where we think that things should go and
reveal our moral compass because the
moral the technology doesn't have a
moral compass of its own yeah I actually
think that there's one twist to this
right so like most of the things that
you talk about aren't directly like put
your money X right like you're not
giving like an investment advice and so
what ends up happening is like one of my
business partners basically says all
time that for everyone
computer science engineer that we
graduate in the u.s. South Korea
graduates like 40 or something or 17 I
think it is but for every one
lawyer they graduate we graduate like 40
here in the US and so like that's like a
country of wealth creation and we're a
country of wealth redistribution and the
legal frameworks and that plays out in
finance all time like right is people
are always looking for like oh you gave
financial advice they lost money and
they all freaked out and so what I think
it's up happening is there's actually
like a scale of objectivity and
subjectivity and where I completely
agree with you though is in things like
what technology should be used for the
security components like all of that
stuff I think it's actually a
requirement it should be to some degree
of like your contribution to society is
if you have a platform and voice like
you have to stand up for the things that
you believe in and your point about that
goes all the way up to the top of the
CEOs of these companies and all the way
down to the the users that have the
platforms with them I think we'd be
better off if more people took that
position frankly yeah yeah we can be
subjective with our hearts and minds but
it's probably good to be objective about
the wallet yeah a great way to put it
listen Josh I appreciate you doing this
we're on where can people get directed
you want them to go to Twitter or
somewhere else yeah so if you go to my
Twitter that's at Josh Constantine or
just search Josh from TechCrunch on
Twitter you'll find me you can follow me
there and I also have a newsletter
that's through the site called review
it's called moving product if you search
for Josh consti moving product you can
sign up for my newsletter which is
coming up and it's about discussing
product and technology through a
sociological lens about how we interact
with each other and trying to talk about
some of that moral compass of how do we
guide the world towards making things
that are not only fun but also
productive and safe well making sure
that we still embody that like wild wild
west zeal that is I think why a lot of
us got into technology in the first
place I love it other than we got to get
you off the review and onto a sub stack
but we'll talk about that later so
alright listen I appreciate you taking
the time to do this and walk through it
again thanks again